social media is like a fake reality
that's the way to look at it see a
picture of someone looking so happy but
we don't know it's what's behind that
picture I always remind to my children
or to my friends is that no one's
showing the argument the bad the the
background you know the reality of life
and you know and it makes you feel like
my life is purposeless I used to post
food during Ramadan and I completely
stopped doing that because there are
people out there who do not have food
who cannot get married who cannot have
children we never get to see the
negative aspects or we think it's all
Rosy and cozy and the first day you see
her without makeup you're saying
however there's a lot of teenagers out
there and from what they have seen when
it comes to being a Muslim couple is
very boring it's very blank they have
that stereotype like you know the woman
just stays at home all day and does
cooks and Amanda's comes and works and
he just comes home and he's a grumpy old
man what is your motive what is your
intention why are you even putting it
out there if you're really that truly
grateful for what you have go and thank
Allah why don't me I don't I don't need
to see it she will be unhappy with you
as a hospital she's exactly because you
are not doing the same time
I feel like you're on social media and
you've opened yourself up you could only
open yourself up to much worse on social
media than seeing a happy Halal marriage
I want to see both sides if you're going
to be honest if you're going to be just
I want to see the dark the
and I want to see the good show me that
oh you just want to show me the good
side why just the good side people are
looking at social media couples because
they're unhappy with their own
relationship they're looking at
idealistic women because they're unhappy
with their own wife
no
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a sadakhajari for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you and the shall be working award click
the link and donate what you can
assalamu alaikum to your brothers and
sisters and dear friends hope you guys
and welcome to another episode of The
Bitter truth show
um before I start I want to praise Allah
the most merciful the most trust or
Praises glory and gratitude belong to
him I want to thank uh my blood brother
who's here my uh Cameron Abdul Kareem
Mohammed jabi
um and us for making all of this happen
may Allah blessing without them I can't
do it and I want to thank the core
producer which is my wife who helps me
decide these topics and bring them
together and kind of manages their
sister's side while eating pizza
yes okay so basically today's topic is
very interesting and I've been meaning
to talk about this topic for a very long
time because it's pertaining and I
believe it's one of the reasons why
there's a false expectation in marriage
marriage is breaking down and most of
the times when we think about Allah says
in the Quran that tell the believing
mental over your case good but what
happens is that also it tells a woman to
lower the Gaze as well but I feel as if
the sisters don't know where their gaze
when it comes to other people's
marriages
so I believe men don't know the case
when it comes to the opposite gender you
know we are visual creatures and that's
our weakness so we don't know our gates
and we should it's a sin but I feel as
if sisters don't know the Gaze when it
comes to other people's lives her
husband is doing this and they are here
so these social media couples that we
are talking about here we're going to
react to some of them I'm trying to get
the videos just to cook disclaimer we
don't want to buy we don't want to
slander we don't want to talk ill of
them we just want to talk about this
phenomena yeah in a nutshell I will get
the videos I'll try to find some we can
watch them but let's get into the topic
so irresponsible social media couples
let's start with the system do you guys
believe
you guys are females you guys know
yourself best
do you not believe that when you see
videos as a young sister some of you
guys are married some of you guys are
divorced so as a young sister when he
was young when you see these social
media couples who are portraying their
lifestyle and it's glamorous and
sometimes you wonder did they take these
videos in Jannah because everything
looks so damn perfect I dream is there
any fault in this video now and the
thing is everything from him from bed
sheets to that flower in the background
to the baby what they're wearing to
whatever they're driving on the holidays
they're going to does it not give a
false perception of what marriage is
because I don't know brother or sister
if you punch their face before you made
that video and made it look like you
know what this is amazing and then I
don't notice that if you try to uppercut
him and then after that you said ah
let's put a picture up yeah because I
believe it's impossible for you to have
such an amazing life now may Allah bless
you guys preserve you guys
protection from envy and which is very
interesting
his father said to him do not mention
your dream to your blood brothers and
we've got social media couples
like everything in their life now of
course there's a balance there are those
who subhanas sometimes they give little
romance here that's fine I'm talking
about those who are showing extravagance
yeah we're traveling here and there do
you guys not believe that is
irresponsible behavior and in a nutshell
I want to say showing off maybe come
showing off but you're given a false
perception of marriage
I think I think it does um one of the
massive issues I have and you have
limited it to couples but I think many
Muslims are con I mean or human beings
are concerned by wife of a woman over
exposing men over exposing but you want
to maybe Target the topic to the couples
and it is true and it has even though we
we like to say no I'm not influenced I'm
very independent I have my own
perception that's not true because when
all day long you keep swiping and seeing
those things you you are affected even
concentrate you you are affected and one
of the things I always remind to my
children or to my friends is that no
one's showing the argument the bad the
the background you know the reality of
life and you know and it makes you feel
like my life is purposeless those people
have a better life those people are
exposing their blessings but they're not
exposing the test that comes with those
blessings and people need to understand
that that all the blessing that you have
you you you do not know about that test
and sometimes it makes us ungrateful of
all the amazing blessing that Allah is
best spawn upon us we do not know what
happens behind the scenes and the
reality of the love of the couple and
it's really like you said a deformed
reality and I definitely think it has a
negative impact on the marriages today
that's for me or the perception of the
marriage
um
personally
uh I believe in the intention of those
who may be posting these things so as
somebody who does post content I cannot
be a hypocrite and say that I do not
post content I do Post content not of me
and my husband not of my children but I
do Post content of cooking but my
intention
my intention is to teach those women out
there who may not know how to cook teach
recipes you know show you know anything
to do with femininity but I wouldn't
want to be judged based upon my content
however
yes so the prophet Muhammad sallam said
when you have something good you should
cover it or you should hide it do not
tell people what you may have or what
you you know what goodness you have
um I I remember before I used to post I
I know I keep bringing it back to this
but I used to post food during Ramadan
and I completely stopped doing that
because there are people out there who
do not have food who cannot get married
who cannot have children and they may
Envy you and they may have this hurt and
sadness and as Muslims we are not
supposed to afflict pain onto others so
I can agree with that point of view
where if that may call was another
person pain or a hungry person to feel
more hunger then it's best to refrain
from it
I also feel like it's definitely down to
your intentions like for example like
you say like you didn't realize what you
were doing like when you were posting
those things like uh sartaj and I we
post things on social media of our
family lives of like you know just just
daily lives of us and things like that
and no we don't post things about
um if he's got on my nerves or whatever
you know we won't post that but I also
feel like
you've got to understand the intention
behind people who don't post things for
example I won't go on there and post
that we've had an argument or something
but we will post to make awareness that
like you know there's lots of reasons
why we do videos together
and which some people won't understand
but at the same time I feel like
everyone has to take social media with a
pinch of salt like you either
everyone has a different take on things
so if you are that person who is easily
easily influenced by social media and or
if you are quite an envious person some
people are more so of some things than
others like materialistic things and
things like that or marriages and
relationships I feel like
you need to know what your limits are
and and how much exposure you're giving
yourself to those things online on
social media that's kind of my well I
want to say social media is like a fake
reality that's the way to look at it see
a picture of someone looking so happy
but we don't know it's what's behind
that picture you know I mean people take
photos of themselves looking happy
because they're unhappy you know so the
thing is that's the way to look at it I
mean yeah me and my wife do videos but
we're trying to motivate the youngsters
to have you have a Halal marriage have
kids because nowadays people don't want
that you know and I get loads of people
I looked your video and I have a good
marriage when I find a good wife I want
to have kids so that's the way we should
use social media for a positive thing if
you start showing your life your cars
they'll see these brothers get cars
showing the cars off and all that stuff
and that that's like it's just a wrong
thing to do especially like showing this
the couple like you know a magic magic
life and that is not true everyone knows
that was married that you have good days
and bad days and if you don't have good
days and bad days you know you're not
you don't know you're married and that
because you know every we all have up
and downs in that but I say social media
is a fake reality that people will show
that oh this is our life trying to
um what you call it promote this good
life and in a happy life but it's not
everyone I know on social media when you
meet in the real life they're depressing
like they're depressed you know I mean
they're thinking oh you know this stuff
but when you see them on social media
with their new bag or the new car and
stuff I'm not thinking what are you
doing bro you know it's true and by the
way I've seen you guys content by the
way like I've I've seen Etc there's some
funny ones and by the way yeah may Allah
bless you guys and preserve your
marriage yeah
um and I'll be honest with you I don't
see you guys in that category and I'm
not saying that because you guys are
here I'll be very honest because if I
did feel like I would not put you on
this specific episode
um you guys are not there like showing
like showing off like hey look what I'm
driving this that you guys are talking
about family unit there is nothing wrong
with someone saying you know what for
example this is how I discipline my kids
for example me and my wife have an
organization educational educational I'm
talking about these individuals who are
totally irresponsible in the sense of
like you said maybe there are people who
are not married yeah no this doesn't
mean you can't put I understand I
understand what I'm trying to say but
the point is this though you're putting
a lifestyle this false reality here and
you're making it seem as if that is what
marriage is and you have millions of
youngsters single Muslims who are
looking at this who are sisters who are
married your sisters can be very
delicate okay very delicate they come
yes and they're coming into this
marriage and then there's an argument
that happens and they see the the
husband raises his voice a bit and she's
thinking Rob I was watching all these
videos it's not supposed to be like this
I'm in an abusive marriage I'm like well
sister relax yourself yeah like it's
it's arguments happen you're going to
raise your voice to him yeah there's
going to be things that's going to
happen these are like my mom says the
salt and pepper of relationships of
marriage so going to zeeshan
inshallah
do you not believe this is
irrespability
a certain lifestyle even
if cost
of young single Muslims are going to
watch this and bear in mind what we
consume look if I have something bad I'm
going to vomit out I have to go hospital
we consume with our eyes and our
thoughts
yeah so when it comes to movies because
we were talking about the media when it
comes to movies
um in movies the characters are always
doing something there's always an
activity there's always a cataclysm
there's always like a world event in
which they need to work together or
there's something that will inspire that
spark but unfortunately when you get
married
there's there's no cataclysm it's pretty
mundane it's pretty boring and you have
to create your own interest when you
look at social media again everyone's
smiling everyone's happy but when you
get married and one person's coming home
from work and you know the house is not
clean or you have to you know make some
food and that food is not tasty like you
start thinking like what what the hell
is this yeah and then even when you go
outside you go outside you see everybody
at restaurants they're sitting together
having a nice time the thing is we never
get to see the negative aspects exactly
we never get to see the negative aspects
so we think it's all Rosy and cozy and
the first day you see her without makeup
you think yeah
because we hardly ever see my teachers
I see I see my teacher showing up I you
know every woman that I see on TV with
the makeup in the magazines I see people
with makeup my neighbors wearing a
makeup the dog's wearing a makeup I mean
everyone's wearing the makeup and then
when I see my wife you know or you know
whatever careful
by one of the levels
because I will not cut it
my wife knows you know what I'm saying
but but the thing is that look when it
comes to these things we we have a very
unrealistic expectation and the thing is
I've heard of people as well that when
they get married they're like oh I hope
we never get arguments I I hope you
don't get angry
anger is a part and parcel of Life Allah
got angry sahaba got angry but it's the
way you
Express that anger and it's the way you
recover and you deal with that anger
that's where the issues are are you
going to get angry and say or are you
going to get angry and say you know what
I'm gonna go like take a half an hour
break and then we resume after half an
hour yeah the anger is normal and the
thing is that look people that say oh no
arguments look and I would say to the
social media guys as well we want to see
more conflict resolution because that is
the biggest problem when conflict
happens people just want to cut and go
when you look at old couples and they
sit down and they ask for advice oh you
know you're 99 years old how are you
surviving they say nowadays people just
want to cut and run we when there were
arguments we didn't want to cut and run
we wanted to resolve and join things
so conflict resolution is so so
important and if that's more kind of
normalized I look arguments happen and I
give this analogy when an argument
happens yeah or it doesn't have to be an
argument it could just be a discussion
or debate why is it seen as a bad thing
or a negative thing if somebody is
staying in a property for one day that
person is not gonna whip out the pain
the wallpaper they're not gonna start
fixing the floorboards that person's
only there for 24 hours they're just
going to survive put a blanket down in
the morning they're gone if somebody
plans to stay there they're going to
tell you look babes you're putting on a
few pounds you know not say it like that
but there's ways that you do it that
like some some Partners they say look if
you see or you want me to do something
different please let me know I don't
want to find out in a different way I
don't want it to come out in a in an
argument or something like that and
there's ways that you do it you could
say look uh should we you know watch
what we eat should we go jogging
together should we you know get a
subscription to the gym and the other
person and they say you know sometimes
even a sign is enough for the other
person to kind of know so these sorts of
things are incredibly important and if a
person is telling you and talking to you
and sometimes there are clashes that's a
good sign it means they want to stay
with you somebody that's just letting
you do whatever that person doing some
Madness behind or somewhere else they're
just trying to keep you sweet and trying
to keep you happy so look this this is
this is great this is real this is
reality yeah when stuff goes wrong
that's good you're getting to know your
partner and the thing is unfortunately
and sadly because we are not used to
this and with the whole snowflake
generation the whole I want to identify
as a pogo stick therefore I'm a pogo
stick so it it's like oh I'm sorry you
didn't what's a pogo stick it's you so
so when when somebody remembers me you
walked into that one Ali sorry
so so the thing is when
I'm seeing this so many Clips like how
dare you not say my pronoun oh my God
I'm this I'm that I'm feeling like this
I'm not feeling like that this gender is
ridiculous you know this look we're
supposed to be people that should be
able to handle pain handle hardship this
is something that builds character a
marriage in which yeah I was gonna say
just one more thing a marriage that is
unrealistically
unrealistically speak first
unrealistically Rosy and cozy that's
just that's just weird like that's
that's not a relationship like you like
that person is not being honest if they
are not saying you're not progressing
with each other yeah like it's changing
yeah I was gonna say
um I think as a ummah we need to take
accountability for what we consume and
what we watch yeah your favorite word so
in terms of I think a lot of us need to
build mental toughness imagine we cannot
even handle social media just imagine
when the the gel comes just imagine so
if you cannot even handle social media
influences and how it impacts your life
please you are not ready for the Battle
of this this actual life and ummah and
the day on the era when we have to stand
for 50 000 years
come on we need to build mental
toughness now for me personally read
books okay yeah even if even if
we're in a social media era yes everyone
what we're watching I agree yeah exactly
that's what I'm saying
so is it out okay okay
there's one thing that's your mind yeah
I was gonna say the the responsibility
the person inflicted this the people
creating the content are just as much
victims of social media as the ones who
are consuming it so
if if I know as a person look
social media affects me I get jealous I
want this I am this I need this I want
this I'm red eye every minute I want
something somebody else has get off
social media yeah go and read a book
take accountability we cannot always
blame the people who are creating the
content because again we are living in a
social media era people make money from
it okay so that means okay one second at
the cost of Look Look let me tell you
something here Mike
let me see I'll give it myself as an
example yeah there's a lot of things
that I can do that I can include my wife
in so much stuff well let me tell you
something my channel will pop off
different level I don't and let me tell
you something I have to beg my wife on
certain videos because she hates it I'll
be honest with you and I hate it you
know why because when she's in it and
then she's like can you blur here I'm
like brother blurred everything out
you're fully out she's like no about my
things I'm not allow me to take it she's
like and then we have that new arguments
here I'm like look you agree to her
she's like yeah but I told you and I was
like but I'm doing a video about her own
relationship I need a woman that you're
my wife I have to touch yeah so the
thing is of course I need you so we did
one about
um
um I buy a new house or something our
house or something like that yes I know
people are going to be nosy yeah like oh
my gosh that was house so they didn't
know that I was in I wasn't I was in a
graveyard yeah okay so I was doing a
video in a graveyard and I saw like a
bungalow looking house and this is a
video I told my wife before because I
tell them my ideas yeah so she can help
me uh develop them so I saw it and I
called her I said listen get into the
car if you share the car I said get into
the car and come here and she's like why
I said that video said no no please
you don't understand it's going to Power
video you're at the Burger bro she came
it was like a bungalow and I was like
yeah this is my wife's house and I said
so just say wow Ali that's very nice
yeah and she was like yeah she said
exactly like you know so a little bit
fake so then anyway so I opened the door
and the next clip is Graveyard so I've
got this is our house that was the point
of the video yeah there's a lot of
people nosy like oh my gosh where did
they live I live in a one bedroom house
with um two three kids uh two kids on
the layer okay so it's that's the
reality which you guys don't think you
think I'm rich millionaire I don't know
what you think of me yeah okay that's
the reality so I was given example but
even in that instance I'm very very
careful because I know it's a
responsibility if I show a certain
lifestyle of hey look at me and my wife
Etc I know at the end of that video I
will never do that video if I know there
is no serious reminder that is the only
conditions I use that I try my best if
we happen to go to Holiday once a year
whenever it may be yeah I do not to tell
people I don't want people people don't
need to know the dream I'm trying to say
but I feel as if today people are too
busy living for others I have to show
that person look how I'm living it large
be it my ex be it to my friend be that
person probably you're not even going
holiday for yourself
to plan holidays for the sake of
Instagram and social media thank you
they plan and go by yourself exactly
only to show it exactly not even leaving
the moment
yeah exactly exactly that is a
responsibility because what you're doing
is for the money the fame the view
whatever it may be at the consequences
of how many people you're going to
corrupt intentionally unintentionally of
course intentions are very important I
think the sister said yeah very
important the intentional important and
we're not saying what you're doing is
Haram the point we're trying to say is
are you that selfish to that level that
you will portray that I dare you I'm
gonna we should start a movement yeah
show us your argument put the camera
there and let me see you guys argue let
me see you guys fight so let me see a
problem in the morning it would be
enough trust me exactly just that's what
I'm trying to say so I don't I don't buy
that I don't buy that they are no I'm so
sorry yeah they play a massive massive
role because there are social media
influencers they have people that are
going to follow them so they are
responsible I I disagree with the thing
but can I just say as Muslims yeah like
we have to think good of people and I
will say some of these social media
influences and Muslim couples because
we're talking about Muslim couples have
actually in a way done a good thing
because there is a Ben I see a benefit
in it because there was a theme or a lot
of people who didn't want to get married
anymore who don't think it's a good
thing so they've kind of made it look
cool again do you know what I mean so
actually there are the youth and the
young people no even the non-muslim
world but to see Muslim couples enjoy in
life and it's not this taboo boring
relationship it is a good thing to see
and it's refreshing sometimes there's a
line there's a line which a lot of
people cross and I think you know not
just big influences but just mediocre
ones what they don't realize is with
great power comes great responsibility
and I don't think they are equipped to
handle that responsibility and not just
that I think it's like what is your
motive what is your intention why are
you even putting it out there if you're
really that truly grateful for what you
have go and thank Allah why are you
telling me I don't I don't need to see
it and the other thing is like for
sisters and brothers who are on social
media first of all why are you even on
there I personally don't think we need
social media yes it can be helpful but
again if that's the case know your
boundaries if you can understand that
this is affecting me get off it do a
detox create those boundaries within
yourself because after all you're going
to be responsible for your time but
you've invested in social media which is
basically what you know benefit whereas
if you had read the Quran you would have
got something with Allah
as well why are they doing it now we I
see this trend of videos the routine the
getting us doing their bed praying this
a lot and that's so good why why do you
ruin it yeah
if I do bro before you do before I speak
can we just before wow
you see why I don't speak on their
podcast last time I didn't speak I got
blame for it this is one you know why it
doesn't let you speak on this podcast
I'm not speaking no more
bro
I'm sitting there wasting away okay
now
no anyway I'm joking about everyone's
wrong but I just have a slight
disagreement and I agree on some points
here so first and foremost down to
people's intentions we never know what
people's intentions are yeah there are
some people and some Muslims that might
go in and just want to show their
lifestyle off and they they might have
like you know uh they're just they're
just not sincere with their intentions
however like Sister Mary said uh there
are couples out there that might just
want to show hate you know what you can
be married and still be lit you can be
married and still have fun you can you
can still be married as a couple
um and go and travel the world and have
like a really
um kind of luxurious lifestyle
and I think everyone in this room is
probably at a certain age where we're
coming into like our mature years now so
we're speaking from our point of view of
being now adults however there's a lot
of teenagers out there and from what
they have seen when it comes to being a
Muslim couple is very boring it's very
blank it's they have that stereotype
like you know the woman just stays at
home all day and does cooks and Amanda's
comes and works and he just comes home
and he's a grumpy old man so I feel like
when you are seeing these things uh even
even me I go on social media and I see
some Muslim couples I'm like you know
what that looks really cool I can't wait
to get married beforehand I'm not gonna
lie that maybe that same stereotype
entered my mind but I'm like oh I feel
like it it's just a burden I'm gonna get
burdened all the time not saying that is
by the way but you don't have a certain
expectation when you watch that do you
not say that okay because when you
watching the words we're using is the
wrong words it doesn't turn as I let's
turn let's change the word from
expectation to aspiration
we can do this all day long but what I'm
trying to say is it depends how we uh
discipline ourselves because now I won't
sit sit down all day long and watch the
social media couple and lust over their
lifestyle because I'm gonna know it's
not a reality maybe but the woman the
woman the females do no I only I do
understand that yeah but at the same
time
no I'm saying me as a grown man you know
as a grown man yeah
that is so cool like that's so lit like
I can't wait to do that but I've even
been I've even considered would I even
be one of them couples that is all cute
and does them little cute videos yes I
probably got too much jealousy I don't
know to see my wife well I it's I I do
find it quite nice that I bought okay
when it comes to a whip to women it's
just like I don't know man I feel like I
just feel like we're nitpicking a little
bit Yeah because there's so many other
worse things we could look on our
screens
about 12 times you know why you're
saying that because you're a man one of
us when we're looking back we would
never be like oh yeah it's nice
what is the problem
so just gonna watch this video and by
the way before I start um
discipline too you can't just say
something in this last room I'm sorry
that's in the nature
guys
our sponsored Nations blend me Allah
bless them because a lot of money ever
goes into this hiring the team etc
for the brothers strong come on Big
Mountain black seed oil capsules uh
honey you name it Angela they have it
checking for Ramadan sisters they help
this podcast happen may Allah bless them
inshallah get into the topic I'm going
to show you guys a video and once again
uh may Allah protect this couple from
Envy to see they're gonna have a child
may Allah bless that child we're just
watching it to understand inshallah so
here it is I don't know where I'm going
to put it I'll let you guys see it first
as well
oh my God I'll give them is that music
yes
okay so for the brothers for the
brothers quickly for the brothers again
there we go so this is the the brother
sister I don't see nothing wrong with
that I've shown you them before haven't
I yeah okay yeah I can see why though so
okay look guys guys look look again yeah
we asked Allah to preserve their
marriage protect them from Envy jealousy
may Allah may Allah them to have more
children
the point is the following when a young
girl looks at that yeah as men we Aspire
they have expectations yeah no that's
not problem for us
so so there's two things here thank you
sorry
yeah so the thing is there's there's two
different perspectives and Views here
yeah now I actually agree with uh Shakil
and the sister as well because she said
for people that aren't that aware of
Muslim marriages it does seem very plain
very boring in fact we don't see it it's
not represented in the media it's not
taught and in fact Muslim couples are
told uh apart Islam to kind of keep
their romances and stuff like that
secret not to do public shows showings
of affection so now their lifestyle
seems better than our lifestyle so when
you do see couples uh doing couple
things and it's appealing I think that's
actually healthy however so that's with
some people now with other people that
have kind of gone past that and said
okay I'm I'm okay I I know that we can
also be happy as well now it goes to the
next level which is is that what we're
seeing is that realistic and not
everybody can discern between realistic
non-real not everybody has those kind of
mental blocks in place how because when
we're young from a very small age when
it comes to drinking when it comes to
voting when it comes to everything else
16 or 18. when it comes to the same
things the same dopamine release little
kids as young as five and six are
getting that same dopamine release that
16 18 year old is getting so you cannot
now expect a child to and and being a
school teacher as well
when I tell parents look don't let your
child have a phone
majority if not all parents say oh but
they're gonna come home they have to
have a phone and this and that when it
comes to social media they always come
and cry and I say look if your child's
on Tick Tock you should be a Mufti of
tick tock yeah you should be a sharehold
Hadith of tick tock like you need to
know that upside down huh
well okay so you need to know that app
that your child's on but the thing is
parents unfortunately because of
capitalism and stuff like that they're
not home and because of the topics that
we've been talking about ups and fathers
and stuff like that parents can't keep
on top of this stuff so social media
given to a child is like arming them
like to their teeth that child cannot
handle that so expecting them to control
and stuff like that is going to be very
difficult to maneuver around and it's
going to spill onto videos like this
the Gen z's are not going to be able to
say okay I can descend from this or I
can tell this so I can do that so the
thing is that Shaquille's thing I see
does make sense because some people do
need to know that aspect but to a point
that okay I get it now but now what
happens
well everyone is trying to do it no but
that's the thing you you can't now say
that everybody has to give a realistic
view of marriage that's the thing not
every social media person can be seen to
know you have to take all five boxes
some people are going to take two boxes
some are going to take three boxes it's
unrealistic to say every social is it so
hard not to show your lifestyle it's all
really hard like I'm trying to
understand it's so hard that I bought I
bought something from my wife
especially not natural it's actually not
natural to to start you know get up in
the morning say I look like a piece of
crap and yeah I'm gonna take a selfie no
we don't want to see your piece of crap
face to that person and we don't want to
see your glamorous face here both of
them are fake because in the morning you
know you can look better I'm sure and
when you wear makeup for some brothers
whatever it may be it's all fake we're
seeing we don't want to see it
so firstly I just want to touch upon the
point and this little excuse that we're
giving women to be jealous yeah hasn't
is a sin to be jealous and envious yes
it's it's no but it's a sin and if you
are afflicted with jealousy work on that
pray on it work on it because it will
guess what jealousy kills you first
before it kills anybody else so we need
to firstly stop giving women excuses
because I'm not a jealous person not all
women are jealous some women have I
personally I don't ever look at
somebody's life and think I want it yes
I can feel inspired okay but that excuse
of women being jealous it makes them get
away with a lot of bad behavior and and
it they get bitter and then say Oh I'm
just a woman I'm just a woman I I'm can
be jealous no it's it you will go to
your grave alone and if you have a
mustard seed of hasid which you've
allowed to overtake your life is very
dangerous yeah and furthermore arrogance
jealousy whatever the case may be but
furthermore uh social media
yes I agree if we over share if we put
on there and the intention is wrong and
you're you're doing it to show others
that you are better okay I can see that
point but there are benefits to like
zeeshan said brother zeeshan said you
know we need that representation
it's a fantasy representation I do not
mind I can agree with what brother
shepman said with the what brother
decision and you said if it is realistic
exactly I like the fact that they're
showing okay the good party encourage
our daughters to trust men again and men
to trust sisters again and to see the
happiness of March but they need to show
problem solving struggle complications
Communications exactly and and how they
are navigating through the marriage
exactly otherwise you're gonna expect
the person
in the Quran there's benefits but the
harm is greater so we cannot say that
the harm is
catastrophic bro bro look at the
difference with alcohol bro bro bro let
me tell you something I can't make a
compressor what I'm seeing is this here
can we come and say the harms the good
outweighs the harm no way bro there's
you know how many people are getting
divorced the divorce rates are crazy bro
people think I started the show for a
joke I was bored at home and I thought
I'll beat the truth I know let me make
some views and fame and whatever it may
be bro I see this in front of me people
are getting divorced Left Right Center
Bros
they play a massive role Brothers the
fingers looking that's sister I agree
with you in one sense because give the
responsibility
to the viewers let me finish it and then
yeah please because otherwise I've been
taking up contacts yeah if you go to
that sister or the sisters who are doing
these things and you said to them do you
feel jealous or somebody else I don't
feel jealous at all you know why because
you've got everything and you're doing
it of course you're not going to be
jealous you think you're going to be
jealous if I had everything going for me
and I'm like I don't feel jealous at all
so the point is they are irresponsible I
believe they are responsible okay
remember there's levels to life though
bro
I just want to say that I want to remind
the accountability of the viewers you
are watching them you are following them
so don't complain if you do not have
their lives or whatever I'm just saying
that we should filter if I am feeling
envious or I'm feeling that you know
like whenever I follow someone and I
have this Vibe like oh oh I don't have
this
unhealthy what is she's giving me even a
smile even non-muslim I follow them I
don't mind as long as they're giving me
something we have to be more careful
more responsible on who we follow and
who we allow to influence us nobody is a
strong like you though sister not
everyone can say I'm going out no no I'm
just like the brother said like you know
like those blockages mind blockage when
you can differentiate reality and life
many young people who are influenced by
materialism are going to be like I know
I'll just unfollow they're gonna be like
no I want that lifestyle we have John
courage
um just about this particular sister
correct me if I'm wrong so I do follow
her in fact and um I think she actually
shared an issue that she had which was
infertility which was really helpful to
see especially for someone like my
friend for example is always going it's
going through something similar so it
was really nice to see that but I think
at the same time it's like this goes in
regards to everything in Estonia like we
can't control people's actions but we
must learn at all costs to control our
own reaction whether it is a social
media whether this is a conflict outside
of home whatever it may be and I think
if you know it's like I mean there are
some people that I follow and these
people bless their hearts they are like
villagers and they have nothing going
for them yet they have like they do work
in a way you know like they just show
The Bare Basics of what they're doing
you know how difficult their life is and
well like it grounds me so much and I
think that's that's what we should be
following that's what we should be you
know looking at use social media as a
platform to remind yourself of how
grateful you should be and how blessed
you are not other things that you're
lacking it's okay to look at something
that you want but don't forget about
what Allah has blessed you with and what
you currently have as well because the
minute you start to bring in the what
ifs then oh if only that's literally the
minute you're handing your power over to
the devil
I just want to say social media
opposition is true because you see
people like about that Prime drink
people were just watching it they didn't
it didn't even taste nice but people
watch this so much that they wouldn't
buy it you know what I mean so the thing
is when we see so things on social media
we need to control ourselves and really
people are getting addicted to social
media like they're brainwashing them
like I'll say if you watch it like a
fast and furious film you get in your
car and you think you're driving fast
but it just like it brainwashing us
tonight you know what I mean so the
thing is we have to think about these
things that what we're watching and what
we're putting out there the thing is
when I put social media videos out there
I want to see if kids can watch it and
everyone else can watch it what they're
gonna if I'm giving good advice what
they're gonna get out of it you know I
mean if they're going to pick good
advice but give me a me and my wife done
a video that you know if you have an
argument don't sleep on it you know I
mean make sure you sort out before you
go you know yeah that's what we're going
to pass on that you know so the thing is
like you know there's all this uh do
feel like sorry to interrupt such but I
do feel like the couple that we just
watched on there and there's loads of
other videos like that and Tick Tock is
like it but I feel like they do more
good than bad for other people so that
might Inspire other people to again yeah
I mean that might be you might disagree
but I feel like they do more good than
bad because I feel like you're on social
media and you've opened yourself up you
could only open yourself up to much
worse on social media than seeing a
happy Halal marriage
can we talk about that kindly just
session on that point you're right
because you know what it is when we look
at it from Face Value why are they doing
wrong nothing they're married they're
showing like they're going places you
can nobody can come and see what they're
doing when we look at this certain
there's direct consequences and there's
indirect consequences sometimes you do a
and it's like this is
a consequence or implicit there are
certain things that are done that have
Ripple effects which are consequences
which are greater if a majority of
younger single Muslim women males and
females are watching this and I have an
expectation by the way I don't believe
these these couples have an intention of
waking up to destroy marriages no way I
assume the best that they're just doing
it to motivate 100 that's why I have I'm
not blaming them in the sense
it can have that effect you know why
sister it gives a false expectation now
if young Muslims are watching this and
they have this false expectation and
they are getting married and realizing
hold on a second I didn't expect to be
like this promise let me watching
Superman and say wrong let me put a
coupon and jump on the 10th floor and
I'm like I died and I go oh why did that
go are we 10 years old because yeah yeah
it's it's fake no that's the reason
hello the example is a bit extreme but
no no no no no you're not no no one
second one second
guys one second why why wasn't why is it
extreme if the if a person has been
brainwashed to a level where they're
consuming something so much so that they
believe that there is true in marriage
and then if somebody watches something
and he goes and by the way forgive me
educational purposes
do you know how many men watch
pornography
okay one second and they watch
pornography and have a false imagination
of how intimacy me should their wives
tells me they come to the Sharia Kansas
bro forgive me
they don't even have intimacy with their
Partners let me put like this they can't
have intimacy with their opponents
without going into detail yeah because
their brain is why the dopamine is wired
to a fake reality so much so that their
wife doesn't even do anything to them
bro so this is how detrimental is and
that's of course it's something very
very Haram but the point is this when
these couples come out and put this
lifestyle it is irresponsible I don't
need to see your life bro enjoy it may
Allah give you more the point is this if
you're going to show me all that
beautiful side to it or 10 seconds or
whatever it may be which is not real
please show me the times where you're
fighting each other in front places yeah
oh not that you guys doing that but if
you're doing that I want to see both
sides if you're going to be honest if
you're going to be just I want to see
the dark the ugly and I want to see the
good show me that oh you just want to
show me the good side why just the good
side
so can we just mention another issue I
have no issue with this couple may Allah
bless them I don't think they have bad
intention and I don't want to talk about
the cover but the phenomena because like
the thousands and thousands of people
are following another issue that we
didn't speak about is the fact that
husbands wives on videos and now women
are expecting and demanding and they're
having conflict because they want to be
on social media and they want their
husband to be on social media and this
is for them couple goals
to protect his wife from exposure it's
it's a normal thing for a man and it's a
natural thing now men are complaining
because their wives are is causing fitna
in the marriage because they don't like
show they don't like when the wife
exposed them he has a hack on what
you're going to show on social media uh
if you're gonna show yourself or show
the house that's his house too that's
his life too and it's becoming a
conflict not because of the couple but
because as well of obviously what we are
allowing like in our lives and in fact
guys we need to wrap up the process I
just want to say that life is not a
fairy tale so if you watch something on
social media it's not real life and this
is one say to the youngsters and uh you
know it's this younger sisters and the
brothers I just want to say to you life
is not fairy tale like me and my wife
worked really hard for where we are we
still have our bad days good days but we
work on it so anything you see on social
media looks like a fairy tale is not
real that's one exactly and the other
thing I wanted to say was
um we were talking about control
and the thing is control if you look
from a kind of secular point of view
it's very kind of unrealistic to attain
Islam is one of the well it's the only
most practical way for us to attain
control in fact about a week's time
we're going to be fasting From Dusk Till
Dawn and that's something that a whole
ummah will be doing collectively so
control is something that again it's
it's all well and good telling us look
have control and unsubscribe but the
thing is Islam will equip you to to
practically do those things that's why
you see certain prominent atheists on
stage they'll be saying all this like
Christopher Hitchens but when he comes
off stage he's a he used to be an addict
of whiskey so the thing is that you know
it's important for us to kind of
understand that you know on the one hand
you know we do need to kind of control
ourselves but on the other hand on the
other hand it's Islam that can equip
ourselves to do that and the thing is
the second point I skip my head but
maybe come back to me so I don't need to
go on the negative things if I was
promote because it kind of seemed like
that I'm like there's nothing wrong with
it my point was that I don't think it's
as bad as your uh as you might think it
is I'm not saying for people to go and
just do it but I just don't think it's
really really bad because what my
concern is you know how fast the Muslim
um are quick to start judging people
these lovely brothers and sisters now
will wake up in the morning and see
comments like look at you Dave look at
you showing off your lifestyle yeah
regardless of what they are I just know
I just I just don't think what they're
doing is evil I feel like maybe
everything can balance and like you said
maybe do it in a just way way I don't
think you need to show the bad because I
don't think that's an Islamic ethical I
don't know why people would want me to
show the bad in my life but um
we show the truth if you you don't you
cannot show only one you want to see me
arguing with my wife
crazy people
I just don't think that um yeah I agree
with you I don't think it should be run
down your throat of nothing but good
because anything in the extreme even if
it is hello anything in extreme yes it's
bad and even when it comes to diet too
much water is bad you know what I'm
trying to say so I feel like violence
and maybe not just show good good good
good good because it can cause so let's
see if everything can balance was just
my point but I just don't think it's
evil what they're doing true of course I
don't believe the intent evolved um and
that's the point rather than sister yeah
remember my point yeah
this Instagram is beneficial I was
social media assistant yeah so just as a
because you said resolve con uh you know
like conflict uh resolution and things
like that us me and a few of the sisters
IRA and fahima we have a Muslim mother's
support forum for women who are going
through divorce so that we can mediate
and allow a healthy co-parenting
situation so follow you guys doing that
with this the brothers yes okay
brilliant makes sense with a pizza
okay
one of the things I wanted to say was
escapism yeah yeah a lot of people go to
social media for escapism and social
media is actually going to get worse
with AI artificial intelligence and you
know putting VR goggles and stuff like
that so the thing is we need to look at
the root causes like why why are people
escaping why do people want to escape
because they're not happy with reality
and the thing is it's that sort of stuff
we need to be looking at people are
looking at social media couples because
they're unhappy with their own
relationship they're looking at
idealistic women because they're unhappy
with their own wife they're looking at
you know certain people exploring the
world because they're unhappy with their
life so that is you know something that
really should be explored not as simple
as oh don't watch this don't watch that
I mean
let's take a stock at why you feel the
need to watch that or why do you feel
the need to post your picture maybe that
person generally speaking it was
actually an interview where a person a
celebrity was saying when I see a selfie
of somebody I genuinely think that that
person just wants a love for that day
and maybe they're not getting it and
they need that kind of validation from
from strangers and other people
so rather than us saying like social
media there are deep rooted issues and
it is in the psyche of people like
although we've it's it's social media we
become very unsocial we've become very
awkward with each other we become very
sensitive you know all of these labels
oh ADHD autism there are persons going
around like 17 labels oh I'm this and
that I can't have dairy I can't do this
like what can you do so so the thing is
there's a lot of things to kind of
consider when it comes to this as well
and you know if somebody is doing that
kind of I think it's important to train
yourself and train your children to kind
of rather than plucking at the leaves
and the brown launches look at the roots
of the issue as long as we try to look
for the roots like why is that person
pointing up a picture why like Harry
Potter we're watching Harry Potter let's
see the behind the scenes look how much
green screen they're using look at the
time it takes them to do makeup look at
Hermione without makeup and stuff like
that exactly I'm saying at least you've
got a big problem with makeup without
makeup I don't know how money is
in a nutshell uh one thing about giving
inshallah is an advice to everybody is
understand that Allah has created two
realities here there's the physical
reality and there's a metaphysical
reality here the metaphysical reality is
something you do not see there is jinns
there are shayateen there are evil eye
we do not understand how severe that is
if I told you guys there is somebody
asked you to kill you you call the
police you make sure somebody is next to
you bulletproof vest armored cause we're
seeing there are share teen on your case
one life we do not understand do you
give that emphasis the protection how
many people doing that car bro I mean if
you're a public figure you're not doing
it one lie it's as if get gonna shoot
yourself not literally but you might as
well the point is you are in danger and
what we're saying is social media
couples you are sabotaging your marriage
do you know millions of people looking
at your marriage while light is by
Allah's Mercy that isn't touch you and
we know in Surah Yusuf Allah talks and
says to his father to his own Brothers
don't mention your dream to your own
Brothers biological brothers and we've
got people forget your brothers people
who hate your Gods but they want you to
die they were watching you and you're
showing them look what I'm doing well
lie is by Allah's Mercy that your
marriage a mail will protect you is in
touch it's as if Allah's got a shield if
that was to take him for a second these
eyes will destroy and crumble it in
minutes brothers and sisters from the
bittertube show till next time
the prophet salallahu said whoever built
[Music]
will be there and imagine you see a
mountain and what a lucky person which
righteous person
and Allah says this is for you for me
yes what did I do you allowed people to
pray you built a Masjid I never had the
money to build a Masjid Allah you helped
you gave towards it and Allah gives you
the reward of as if you've built it
don't let it now guys and do not delay
and share the video for extra Rewards
foreign